这是我用AI给星光560做的汽车广告, 全程没有实拍
我是如何做的呢, 一起先看成片
你就不能过来搭把手
搭什么手, 这明显又拉多了
我那箱啤酒和大米放哪儿
每次进货都这样
多跑一趟的油钱都够进两箱纸了
我当初叫你买个大点的车, 你非说没用
那再又来怪我了
带文件, 我哪敢怪你啊
才说你一句, 你就
爸
妈
你快进去写作业
一趟拉不完, 我拉两趟就是了
谁告诉你拉不下的
咱家那车拉不下, 他还拉不下吗
谁
这车可真能装啊
你啥时候买的, 咋不早点给我讲
我这不想给你个惊喜吗
咱们去露营是不是也有着落了
这是我制作时用的画布
大家可以看到一些生成效果
简单讲一下制作思路
这个案子首先要考虑的是
产品是给谁用的
提案的时候我就对准了这种
三四五线的个体经商户小家庭
进行人物关系的设计
爸爸妈妈和孩子
三个人就能交代清楚剧情
所以这是生成视频的制作流程
我其实是分了三个板块
美术概念场景设计
剧情图片生成
和视频生成
生成这种产品广告
比较难的就是产品的一致性
那么这里的话
我会给单独的这个资料
打一个区域用于链接节点
去生成对应的模型
比如说我这里想生成一家人在车里的场景
我其实就可以把这个链接过来
大家可以看到效果还是非常不错的
然后就图生视频
基本上就是你跑出来的分镜头图片
你让角色该做什么就做什么没什么好说的
这种写实的广告
其实我个人认为设计难度和整体完整性是最难的
但做一点点的内容相对是比较简单的
我们其实更看重的是完成度
比如这款产品
其实它的剧情非常非常简单
一句话就能改破完
一个问题的争吵
一个产品去解决问题
能生活能工作
不是意味的去堆参数
告诉你这个产品有多好
广告它传递的其实是情绪和体现产品价值
希望这条视频的制作分享能够帮助到制作人和品牌方
我是罐头
点赞高的话
我持续分享AI创作的幕后和技巧
感谢您的关注
我们下期再见